all right so you know my my group we do
we do both experimental evolution and
some of this theory and usually I talk
about the experiments but in keeping
with the theme today I'm going to talk
about theoretical work done primarily by
Ben good who is sitting right there so
he really should be giving this talk but
because I'm older I'm giving the talk so
anyway direct your questions there yeah
all right so this is the first time I'm
talking about this stuff so feel free to
interrupt if I'm more incoherent than
usual all right so basically what I'm
gonna talk about is trying to understand
what you expect genetic diversity to
look like in the presence of pervasive
natural selection that acts sort of
simultaneously at many low sigh across
the genome and so you know this comes up
in a lot of contexts one example that
we've seen in our experiments is that
we're on long term evolution experiments
in budding yeast and we know that these
populations are experiencing lots of
selection at lots of sites across the
genome and we can sequence a bunch of
individuals from within these
populations and here's an example where
we sequenced a couple dozen individuals
from one of these evolving experimental
populations and we can characterize the
genetic diversity that we see in those
samples of individuals that we sequence
and we can summarize it by a genealogy
here's one example
and ideally this is the sort of data
that one might collect in a natural
population and ideally what we would
like to be able to do is look at this
kind of genealogy and see what
signatures natural selection is leaving
in that data and maybe infer something
about you know how strong selection is
how broadly it's acting from this kind
of data and you know you see similar
things here's a tree of some influenza
sequences drawn by one of our
collaborators on this project I'm going
to tell you about Richard Mayer in a
paper last year and you know we see
certain characteristics of these kinds
of genealogies in the presence of
pervasive selection acting across the
genome things like the skewed branching
which you see in both of these trees
multiple merger events which are not
really characteristic typically of
neutral evolution
even any kinds of even many kinds of
demographic scenarios but the problem is
that it's really difficult to actually
do anything with this kind of data at
the moment because we really have a
shockingly at least shockingly to me
limited understanding of how we expect
this kind of pervasive selection to
shape these genealogies so we don't
really know I can't tell you you know
let's have some model of what the
selection pressures are what the
mutation rates are what the population
size is and what would we expect these
kinds of trees to look like and in the
absence of that it's really impossible
or at least very difficult to make
anything from this from this kind of
from this kind of data all right so what
we did I really should say what Ben did
was and what I'm gonna tell you about is
a project of looking at one very
specific type of pervasive selection and
asking how it influences the kinds of
diversity that we would expect to see
and before I get into that you know for
many of you this will be completely
redundant but I just want to take a
minute or two to highlight what the
essential problem is with the existing
methods and why we need to do some work
to understand these kinds of questions
so you know the standard methods for
looking at this kind of you know data
about diversity within a population I
mean this is obviously way too big for
me to summarize in a couple of minutes
but the basic idea is that what we do
with something like neutral coalescent
theory is we imagine some sample of
individuals from it from within a
population and we calculate the
probability of some particular ancestral
relationship between those individuals
basically some possible genealogy and of
course many of you know that there's all
kinds of things we can say about these
genealogies so if we imagine sampling a
bunch of individuals from the present
you know that these two individuals
might have had a common ancestor in the
recent past these two individuals had a
common ancestor back at this point in
the past these two individuals had a
common ancestor way back in the in the
morgue
passed and based on some idea some
assumptions about let's say what the
population size is what the demographic
structure of the population is we can
say quite a lot about what we expect
this genealogy to look like and then
what we can do is we can imagine that
mutations occur as a Poisson process
across the genealogy and so we can
basically compute the probability
there's some genealogy and then
mutations just occur randomly and that
these mutations then generate a pattern
of diversity that we would you would
observe in sequence status so here's an
example this is the sequence of this
individual here and it it has this green
and this blue mutation this individual
here has the green and this yellow and
the blue mutation and so on right and
the key thing about this is and the
thing that sort of makes this all work
is that we can separate these two
processes we compute the probability of
a genealogy and we compute the
probability of an observed pattern of
mutations given the genealogy and
because we can separate these two things
this this whole approach works and you
know I'm not going to get into the
details but the two sort of key basic
results that will be important for what
I'm going to tell you in the rest of the
talk are that if we think about the
typical time since the last common
ancestor of two individuals if we
imagine some population of some constant
size n ok or alternatively some some
more complicated scenario but some
effective size n the probability in any
given generation two randomly selected
individuals share a common ancestor is
just one over the population size right
the probability you just pick two people
at random from a population they have
the same parent it's like one over the
population size so the typical time
since the common ancestors will scale
with the population size and that means
that the average diversity will scale
with the population size okay and here
I'm just talking about this diversity
pie which just reflects the average
number of sequence of differences at the
sequence level between two randomly
sampled individuals so for example this
individual and this individual differ at
one site so that that pie is one
this individual here and this individual
here if you look at that carefully they
have six mutations that are different
between them so the PI there is six and
of course there's a whole distribution
of this diversity within the sample but
on average it's going to be proportional
to N and we're also going to talk about
frequency spectrum which is basically
saying how many mutations are there that
are present in I individuals out of our
sample I think there are about 12 or 13
individuals here so for example this
mutation here is present in only this
individual okay so that has an eye of 1
this mutation here is present in 2
individuals so that's an eye of 2 this
mutation is present in 7 individuals
that's an eye of 7 and we can calculate
in this model how common we expect
mutations to be that have different
frequencies we expect rare mutations
that are present and only one individual
to be more common to be more frequent
than the mutations that are present in
many individuals ok this is all totally
standard stuff ok but like I said when
we have pervasive selection acting
across the genome this basic separation
between the genealogy and the mutations
on the genealogy breaks because we can
imagine let's say this is a deleterious
mutation we can't just say ok this
happened randomly on this branch because
the fact that there's a deleterious
mutation here makes it less likely that
this lineage has this many descendants
ok so how are we going to address this
so the basic framework that we use the
idea behind all of the sort of methods
that I'm going to tell you about is that
we keep track of not only the ancestral
relationships among individuals but also
the fitness of each of each ancestral
lineage so the idea here is when there's
selection going on there will be some
distribution of Fitness's in the
population some individuals be more or
less fit than others you can imagine
sampling and sequencing a few
individuals and they will have random
fitness ok now think about their
ancestors right you can think about this
just like this is like a little thought
exercise for those of you in the room
how many of you guys have kids
okay how many of you guys don't have any
kids alright so some of you guys some of
you guys are just young but some of you
guys will never have kids right right
it's like that's low Fitness you might
have deleterious mutations something
like that right how many of your parents
but how many of your parents have kids
right
like obviously all your parents have
kids right and your grandparents not
only do they have kids but their kids
have kids right so if you think about it
like as we go back in time you are lower
Fitness I mean some of you have many
kids right bless you but but but on
average right like if we take all the
people in this room all of the parents
of the people in this room will be more
fit on average than all the people in
this room right and if we think back
further in time that gets more and more
true right so like our ancestors the
ancestors of the individuals currently
present in the population will be a will
be a sort of fitter than average subset
of that ancestral population and the
further back we go in time the fitter
and fitter those ancestors were right
and because they're descended from a
fitter and fitter subset of the
population if we think about the
genealogical process right they're sort
of more you're more likely to share
common ancestors because you know many
years in the past there were only a very
small fraction of the population that
everyone is descended from so they're
very likely to be the same individuals
right now we can sort of quantify this
like if we go back in the past we trace
these ancestral lineages they're a bit
thinner they get even more fit and you
know if you look way back in the past
everyone's descended from these sort of
most fit individuals right and so we try
to understand understand this okay now
obviously I can sort of say this
intuitively and talk about talk about
your parents but let's try to make this
a little bit more concrete okay so all
of this you know this business that I'm
telling you about here I mean this
applies regardless of the type of
selection that's going on but if we want
to actually make quantitative
predictions about this sort of stuff we
need a concrete model and so for this
purpose we're going to focus on one
specific type of selection so we're just
going to focus on
pervasive purifying selection that acts
across the genome
okay so we're basically going to say
alright there's a lot of mutations that
can happen that are bad all right and
obviously there's lots of other stuff
too but this is like we know that this
is always the case right there's always
lots of mutations that are bad and so
we're just going to focus on what
effects those mutations have okay and
ask how that would affect diversity and
we can think about beneficial mutations
and so on maybe some other time so the
really simple dumb model that we're
going to look at we're just going to
imagine a population of constant size n
with some mutation rate you okay
genome-wide mutation rate U and we're
just going to say mutations each
mutation that occurs we're going to
imagine a sort of infinite sites model
so each mutation you know occurs at some
unique site in the genome and it has
some fitness effect drawn from some
distribution and there's some
recombination rate okay
and this model is completely unsolved we
have no idea what genetic diversity is
going to look like and I'm gonna
actually tell you an even simpler model
because we're not even going to solve
this this one we're gonna solve an even
dumber model alright this is the even
simpler model okay we're going to
imagine that Fitness effects have one
that mutations have one of two Fitness
effects either zero okay they're they're
neutral or they have some fitness cost s
so there's some deleterious mutations so
then we can just divide this mutation
rate into the neutral mutation rate and
the deleterious mutation rate that's it
okay this is like about as simple a
model involving natural selection that
you could possibly write down hey later
we'll talk about about the effects of
recombination and distributions of
effects right at the end of my talk but
for now we're just going to think about
this very very very simple model and
we're gonna imagine recombination rate
of zero okay so we're gonna be looking
at within a short distance scale within
a genome where recombination is very
unlikely in a sense that we'll get to
right at the end okay so all right
that's the model is this clear what what
I'm talking about
all right so within this model we can do
this kind of tracing of the genealogies
of our ancestors through the
Fitness distribution within the
population in a very simple way right so
we have these deleterious mutations they
have Fitness effect s so if we think
about the distribution of Fitness within
the population some individuals will be
very fit they don't have any deleterious
mutations some will have 1 2 3 and so on
deleterious mutations this is known as a
mutation selection balance it's set by
you know mutations driving you this way
and selection sort of pushing you that
way and so you get some steady-state
distribution you can imagine let's say
you sample two individuals from the
population and you think about their
ancestry we can compute the
probabilities say for example it's
sometime in the past this individual
descended from a more fit ancestor which
had this higher fitness and then maybe
some time even more in the past the
ancestor of this individual was
descended from an individual that had
higher fitness and maybe then this now
these two individuals at this point in
the past had the same Fitness maybe they
had a common ancestor here that had one
deleterious mutation or maybe not maybe
this individual descended from an
individual that is 0 and so on and
eventually they have some common
ancestors we compute the statistics of
all this stuff and figure out what the
genealogy looks like and this is known
as the structured coalescent it was
introduced by Hudson and Kaplan now 20
years ago now and a lot of work by them
and since by some of us has worked out
what we expect that the diversity to
look like how we expect this kind of
selection to influence to influence
patterns of sequence diversity yeah yeah
well so I'm still in like yes but what
we're going to talk about is when we're
not the whole point of this talk is
gonna be what happens when that rates
down yeah but for the moment yes for the
moment we're gonna assume a large
population and where this this
distribution is it's fixed alright until
the next slide alright so if you remove
the recombination yeah signal model why
isn't that
sort of essentially just sort of a
structured coalescing with infinitely
many that's what it is yeah it's a
structured coalescent with yes that's
all this is but the the first model is
that right as a structured yeah right
right right I guess what I what I
shouldn't say is that when I say it's
unsolved what I mean is that I mean you
can you can sort of write down a
structured coalescent as long as this
has a has a has a harmonic mean if it
doesn't have a harmonic mean that
doesn't even make sense however you
can't actually compute anything okay and
as we'll get to in a minute
the structure coalescent breaks down in
many other ways as well okay but we're
coming to that in just a second all
right so the thing that's sort of
well-known and that like you'll see in
textbooks in that everyone sort of talks
about is known as background selection
okay and this is a sort of limit of all
of what I've been talking to you about
so far
when selection pressures are really
strong so if you think that that the
selection pressures are really strong
okay then all of you all I mean you may
have some deleterious mutations but you
must be very recently descended from
individuals that don't have any
deleterious mutations because if those
deleterious mutations are so bad like
your parents couldn't have even had kids
that they have any right so your
ancestors are very recently descended
from this class of individuals that has
no deleterious mutations so we can think
if we sample individually very quickly
they're descended from these individuals
that don't have any deleterious
mutations and then the genetic diversity
within the population is characteristic
of while these deleterious mutations
happened during this sort of most recent
phase of the ancestral history all right
if you think about the three individuals
they very recently descended from this
class of individuals that had no
deleterious mutations and then you have
an essentially neutral process within
this class okay this is called the delay
time this is a coalescent time and when
selection is sufficiently strong this
time is short compared to this time and
basically what you have
all right since there's these great
boards just right up you have okay that
the that the this is the actual yeah
thank you alright that right very good
so yes one is 2.7 and the other is is a
subscript right so you know you can work
out in mutation selection balance this
class will have a fraction of the
population of e to the minus UD over s
so this is the population size of this
class so the neutral coalescing process
within this class will be just it'll be
just a standard neutral coalescent with
this reduced effective population size
and the diversity that you see within
the population will be characteristic of
this plus these little branches right at
the end okay and this is formally exact
in the limit as n s goes to infinity
okay but you have to sort of be careful
what you mean by this if we just take n
s going to infinity okay while keeping
some fixed mutation rate then you'll
just get a neutral population it'll be
as if selection wasn't there if
mutations are really lethal mutations
don't matter so it's formally the limit
as n s goes to 0 while taking n u to
infinity in a way in which n u / NS is
constant okay and that gives you this
this result okay but now as there have
been various questions to describe right
this depends exponentially on UD / s so
it is not very hard at all to imagine
scenarios where if you D becomes bigger
than s okay very quickly this will break
down and this you e to the minus u - u /
s will become tiny and this ne may even
become much much less than 1 okay and
this whole distribution ok that we
talked about here doesn't even make
sense because you can't have less than
one individual right and so this whole
distribution rather than being some
fixed thing will be some crazy
fluctuating thing where a genetic drift
very important okay and I'm sort of just
drawing a schematic here you might
imagine lots and lots of different
classes with very weakly selected
mutations in each class or lots of a
high mutation rate where you do ver s is
large okay
now the key thing is in this sort of
regime there still exists a distribution
of Fitness within the population I mean
of course there's variation in fitness I
mean if you crank up the deleterious
mutation rate you don't destroy a
variation in fitness I mean you still
have variation in fitness it's just
fluctuating all over the place and we
can't sort of draw this this situation
where these this sort of fixed
distribution this these fixed set of of
fitness classes but there's still some
distribution and we'll talk about
there's some variance of this
distribution which depends in some
complicated way on these underlying
parameters okay it's much less than the
variance would be if we you know hadn't
had stronger selection okay but okay we
have this kind of scenario we still want
to predict how genetic diversity is
going to look okay
so if you just run a whole bunch of
simulations so these are just a whole
bunch of simulations that been ran and
what he did was he took a whole bunch of
different selection strengths and also a
bunch of different mutation rates and he
showed that when this any over here when
n e to the minus UT over s times s
becomes of order one okay so that's this
line here where that happens in this
selection versus mutation phase diagram
here in this whole regime or selection
is strong or mutations are relatively
weak all of the predictions of this
background selection this prediction
these predictions here work reasonably
well okay
this blue just means that the
predictions are pretty good in a method
in a way that I'll define well we'll see
more precisely in a minute and in this
whole regime over here all of that stuff
doesn't work okay so this is what we
want to explain that's going to be the
point of what I'm about to tell you
right yeah sorry and what this is these
PI I'm going to talk about PI over PI
not this is the this is the the average
diversity that you see divided by PI
naught which is what it would be in the
absence of any deleterious mutations so
in a neutral model okay so if PI over PI
naught is 1 then the population is based
neutral and as pi over pi not gets less
selection is reducing diversity okay now
we're just gonna present some
phenomenological results in the next
couple minutes so what we saw we noticed
with these experiments is if you take
all of these data points from here okay
and I just plot them as a function of
deleterious load so each of these each
of these points has some selection
strength and some mutation rate if I
just take you over s okay which is what
goes in here okay and for all the
different selection strengths I just
plot them according each point according
to the deleterious mutation rate I'm
drawing all of the points in circles if
they come from this part of the graph
and all the points in triangles if they
come from this part of the graph and
what you see is all the points that have
triangles they fall on this line where
the diversity is predicted by u over s I
should have written you D here this is U
T over s so UT over S tells me what the
diversity is for populations that follow
here independent of what s nu D is in
other words different values of s and UD
give you the same diversity as long as
you do ver s is the same thing as
predicted by this but if you look at
these points over here that doesn't hold
okay however there is something that
does hold which is that if you plot the
standard deviation in fitness okay if
you each value of U D and s gives you
some standard deviation and fitness and
if you predict the amount of diversity
as a function of that all the points
that have different u D and s but that
have the same standard deviation in
fitness give you exactly the same
pattern of diversity okay and the points
that were over here in this background
selection regime that doesn't hold right
so you have these two different things
that predict what diversity you're going
to see in these two different parts of
the parameter space okay and this is
just looking at the at the PI that the
average diversity if you look at the
whole frequency spectrum you see a same
sort of pattern I'm not going to really
get into this in great detail but here's
an example this is the neutral
expectation here's an example of what
the frequency spectrum looks like in one
of these sort
populations in this interference
election regime and you can compute the
minorly average minor allele frequency
or Taj Emma's V or the sort of something
about this this non monotonicity in the
frequency spectrum and again what you
see is that all the populations in this
interference selection regime all if you
can predict let me put it this way if
you can predict the the the standard the
the standard deviation of fitness okay
you can predict the average
heterozygosity this pie and this pie
then in turn tells you what the rest of
the frequency spectrum looks like okay
and this holds just once like this holds
both in these asexual populations and
also with recombination in a way I'll
get to in a minute yeah no this is just
I mean it doesn't matter right so the
frequency spectrum is independent no so
this PI naught is is in the absence of
deleterious mutations so you can see PI
over PI naught of 1 which is over here
at the left obtains if you have either
almost no deleterious load like if you
take uni to 0 also if you take s to 0 so
this goes to infinity you notice you get
to the same thing and in the middle you
have this reduction and it's not you
know this backwards selection it
predicts that reduction ok provided that
we're in this regime where where this
thing is it's large enough okay so it's
not that you can't get a deviation in
terms of the reduction in heterozygosity
okay but from the neutral expectation
okay even so this is yeah okay all right
so what does this predict I have like 10
minutes is that right yeah okay all
right so it turns out that if you think
about these models and and then you know
did long supplementary material which
which y'all can look at if you if you're
interested of this paper that we just
wrote on this just as there's this
background selection limit which
as exact as you take NS to infinity
while holding this thing constant okay
there's also another limit of this model
where you can predict diversity exactly
or at least a little more complicated
that but there's another sort of simple
limit of this model that emerges in the
sort of opposite limit where NS goes to
zero okay and obviously if you just take
NS goes to zero without taking without
doing something else you get a neutral
population same as in the background
selection regime but if you take an NS
going to zero while holding the standard
deviation constant okay so you take n s
going to zero but n you going to
infinity to keep the standard deviation
and fitness constant you get some other
limit of the model known as the
interference selection limit or the
infinitesimal limit as we're calling it
and this is sort of analogous to
quantitative genetics right this is
exactly the quantitative genetics limit
where we imagine that the phenotype in
this case Fitness is caused by a sort of
effectively infinite number of a sort of
very weakly weak effect things it's a
sort of standard assumption in
quantitative quantitative genetics you
have lots and lots of low sigh affecting
the trait each locus has it has an
infinitesimal effect on the train okay
here just the trait is Fitness that's
what this limit is doing and we're
saying we're holding the variance and
fitness constant yeah so you your
parameters here that you have to play
with you win yes so that's a whole
complicated story which I'm not going to
get into but Oscar Hallett check made
this very nice model because so actually
so first of all they're really only two
parameters okay because UN doesn't
affect any of this it just scales the
overall everything so really we just
have u DS that's why I'm in sloppy here
these years are all UD and then this is
s and that's it all right so we have nu
D and n s that's it and using this model
introduced by Oscar how it check in in a
couple years ago I guess 2011 now you
can calculate how this variance in
fitness
depends on you D and s basically it goes
well it's it's complicated then I don't
know if you want to say anything more
specific about it but it's some
complicated function which you can
calculate okay yeah and it's weekly -
yeah it's I don't want to get it say
anything more about it
because I don't have that much time
alright so the upshot is so in this hole
and there's some boundary in between
okay and this boundary is you know
loosely speaking this same boundary that
I've been talking about before when when
any u times s is zero this is where the
distribution of Fitness's starts
fluctuating a lot okay
exactly what this boundary is is a
little tricky but roughly speaking
that's what it is
okay so the idea that we had was that
okay in this background selection limit
we had some formal thing that was true
way out here in this limit but it seems
to work pretty well throughout this
distribution and with the structured
coalescent we can work it out so well
what you could imagine is you take some
population that has some variance in
fitness over here okay we it you know
reduces to some interference selection
limit with the same variation with the
same variance in fitness if we sort of
go off in this direction okay and that
might be a good approximation for this
diversity okay and they're more
generally because we see okay in all of
these plots the standard deviation and
fitness predicts everything sort of
throughout this regime we hypothesize
that any two populations that have the
same variance in fitness in this regime
okay have the same patterns of diversity
that's what these simulations are
telling us so what we could do we could
imagine taking a population that sort of
lives over here compute another
population off in this limit that has
the same variance and fitness okay and
predict the diversity that way a problem
is you can't actually solve this limit
and predict the diversity like you can
for this background selection limit but
what you can do instead okay is you can
say alright this population has this
variance in fitness we know that
populations that have the same variance
of fitness in this
Jeane have the same patterns of
diversity so let's describe let's
approximate the diversity we expect to
see in this population here with the
population way over here on the boundary
that has the same variance in Fitness
and how are we going to do that we're
going to approximate this population as
being in the background selection regime
ok well it's like a really kind of a
funny thing we're gonna take a
population where all of this background
selection stuff is breaking down we're
gonna say it's equivalent to a
population with the same variance and
fitness right on the boundary of this
regime and then we're going to use this
strong selection to predict the
diversity all right and intuitively
what's going on here is this is like
coarse graining the distribution okay
this sort of inspiration for this came
about thinking about the neutral limit
right like if we think about these kinds
of distributions right of the number of
deleterious mutations that each
individual has right this makes sense in
the limit as X goes to zero right I mean
I can talk about the number of
deleterious mutations that you have even
as s goes to zero right but they are
like the whole distribution is
fluctuating all to hell but it we know
that everything is described by this
very simple neutral coalescent and the
reason it works is because we're sort of
forgetting about all those fitness
classes because then they're not fitness
classes anymore right all the mutations
have zero fitness effect so we're just
treating them as one big group right so
the idea was okay what about for small
but nonzero Fitness effects maybe we can
do the same kind of thing imagine you
have some distribution I'm just zooming
in on some piece over here let's say we
have all these different fitness classes
they're fluctuating all over the place
but let's just group together some of
these classes as some sort of
coarse-grained group of mutations right
and so here I'm just drawing some rough
schematic of that right for different of
these classes I'm sort of grouping
together as one class and then I'm sort
of redefining this is my new selective
effect okay and now many of these
mutations that were previously classed
as deleterious now become effectively
neutral because they just move you
within one of these groups and only some
fraction of the mutations are
deleterious the ones that move you
these groups so like in this sort of
context what this is doing it's taking a
larger you know smaller s and a larger u
D and mapping it to a different model
with a larger u D sorry a smaller u D
and a larger s in other words sorry we
are going from here down in this
direction now obviously you have to do
this right okay
you cannot group these things too
broadly because then you will be
ignoring fitness effects that really do
matter and you cannot do it too narrowly
because then the distribution will still
be fluctuating and the methods that
we'll use to predict the diversity using
this background selection ideas won't
work okay and it's not obvious that
there is a mapping that works okay
from this okay but as it turns out and
inspired by these simulations there is a
mapping that works and it's the mapping
that redefines this thing in such a way
that you preserve the same variance in
Fitness okay yes exactly
we're just patching it exactly if
there's this regime in the middle or
sort of it's immediately bad or both are
actually good Oh what are actually
pretty good yeah sorry okay so let me
just highlight the results and this will
get it like how good it is all right
I'll just take another minute or two so
first of all this causes a big problem
of identifiability right it posits that
two populations that have the same
variance in Fitness here but very
different underlying parameters have the
same patterns of diversity and they sort
of look like this so it's actually like
for those of you that sort of read a lot
of this literature you'll often see like
estimates of diversity within
populations corresponding to any s of
order one and what this is saying is
that you know those are populations that
they could have parameters where any s
is of order one but they're also
consistent with all the other sets of
parameters that have the same that would
give you the same variance in Fitness
but might have very different underlying
mutation rates and selective pressures
okay and this is just going back these
red lines now these are the same plots I
showed you a minute
go this is the prediction of that method
that I just talked to you about so it's
really damn good all right here's the
whole frequency spectra there's some
problems in the middle here okay but
these are various populations with
different underlying parameters but that
have the same variance in fitness you
can see their frequency spectra are the
same and this red line is our prediction
pretty good except for a little problem
here which we still haven't worked out
here are various summary statistics of
that at the minor allele frequency
Tajima ste this non monotonicity this is
for recombining as well as non
recombining populations pretty good
alright and the last thing I just want
to tell you about very quickly is how we
include recombination into this right so
so far we've been thinking about asexual
populations but if you imagine a
recombining population what we can do is
just imagine you have some long genome
and imagine two sites very distant okay
if the recombination rate on if the
total number of expected recombination
events in the time since the most recent
common ancestor of some sample is large
between two very distant sites in the
genome these will be effectively
evolving independently on the other hand
if you look at a short distance scale
okay these two sites that are very close
together might essentially never
recombine in the coalescence time so
they're effectively purely asexual okay
and so there's some balance between
these two and there's some sort of
distance scale within the genome which
we are calling a linkage block right and
sites that are close to enough together
they're sort of effectively asexual and
all that I've been telling you about is
applying and then sites that are more
distant you just have independence so we
the the scale of this linkage block is
the distance scale on the genome in
which you will have a border one
recombination event in the time since
the most recent common ancestor and of
course this time to the most recent
common ancestor depends on the size of
this linkage block because the large of
the linkage block is the more
deleterious mutations there are the
higher the UV and that of course affects
this so you have to self consistently
figure out what this is but we can do
that right
and so what we can predict for instance
is how much diversity we expect as a
function of the of the recombination
rate and the mutation rate and you can
see for example this is simulations and
this red line is our prediction these
other lines are various predictions of
some earlier work which as you can see
don't work as well this is the average
diversity this is a measure of the site
frequency spectrum okay and we can also
look at distributions of Fitness effects
I don't want to get into that but here
this is just showing you this diagram
again and what I had is all of these
different lines these different
frequency spectra come from populations
here's a sexual population populations
with different distributions of fitness
effects a finite sites model a model of
the type that an asexual model of the
type that I was telling you about
they're all models with very different
underlying parameters but they have the
same variance in fitness they give you
the same site frequency spectra and we
can predict it pretty well with all of
this course grading idea all right so
that's it this is my this is the the
group this is all work of been good with
our collaborators Alex and Richard
no no we haven't
this is an interesting thing to do I
don't know she wants to look at
essentially all of what I told you about
is looking at each site sort of by
itself and if we look at sort of the the
the correlations between diversity of
sites to say a function of the distance
along the genome maybe there's something
more we could say from that and we have
not done that but it is interesting to
do Richard and Oscar a little bit
similar things like the patient's right
atrium you see similar patterns but I
guess I mean all of this is humans after
the patients on establish right and so
forth the mom is wretched that's not
only for I mean this is basically one
objection
it's not really not really assuming no
metastasis I mean there can be a lot of
epistasis what its assuming is that even
if there's a lot of epistasis
essentially the distribution of fitness
effects is not substantially different
for any two genotypes so you can have
individual mutations have epistatic
interactions with each other but as long
as the distribution of fitness effects
isn't changing wildly between sort of
nearby genotypes then this general thing
will hold but yes it does make that
assumption and when that breaks down
right and there you find it can I just
ask you to you put those last two slides
back and forth and this one about
recombinant before yeah so I was trying
to understand how this why here on the
bottom left is integrated it into this
subber slide that you show it for you to
say that all the things I'm just there's
something integration over the genome of
some way to bring them together so what
one can do essentially is you imagine
you have summary
combination right what you do is you you
just hypothesize that the length of a
leakage block is some number okay and
you compute the time to the most recent
common ancestor using our asexual models
okay that I described to you before all
of that you compute what the time of the
most recent common ancestor okay given
that healthy that LV affects this
because LV is sort of setting
how many deleterious mutations are we
gonna block in other words what the Ruby
is okay so you take the LBD that assumes
AUD you predict this okay then you ask
is this greater or less than one if it's
greater than one okay then you reduce
the LD if it's less than one you
increase the LD you do that and you find
in the LV where this is one okay it's
not really exactly one but roughly
speaking that's what you do so then you
have an lb okay and then you can predict
what the diversity is using our asexual
model with that LD okay and that's how
you make the prediction okay and then
you see that the diversity matches that
from the folding combining simulation
right so this is these are simulations
of like a whole genome with the
recombination and looking at the site
frequency spectrum that just naturally
arises in that position the prediction
comes actually is what the prediction
comes about it is the prediction the
prediction for this of the genome
embassy the prediction is the prediction
of the asexual of the corresponding
asexual model with they'll be defined in
the way that I just described
but you're single but this is just an
approximation okay we're pretty close
right is this for the mean yeah oh yeah
that's right I mean obviously so many
mutations with large effect so you want
to go you want to go here all right
it depends on how you take many
mutations in large effect right if you
just take eskalene to infinity and you
going to infinity at the same rate you
will go off in this direction
all right so that's just one of these
models it's either one of these effects
depending on how far you exactly where
you are it's been very interesting
talking you can talk to more could break
but I think